so I'm talking to a guy that does
valuetainment who is creating content
which is definitely telling you how to
live you wrote a book the laws of doing
the impossible your video that popped
off and went viral was all about how you
can learn and it it I'm going to use my
words now it doesn't matter who you are
today it matters who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there so
help me and maybe there's just another
part of this help me Square the your
sort of the totality of your DNA and
your experiences and then you completely
end up shifting your life you said the
best thing that ever happened to you was
hitting rock bottom because it forced
you to reevaluate your thinking so what
I want to know is right now there are
people watching us and they are
panicking that you're saying that who
they are today is just it's a product of
you know their the culmination of their
DNA and their experience and it's a trap
basically and they are who they are but
I don't think you believe that I don't
think that's what I'm saying though so
how what is that next level of
malleability how much can we change so
what I'm saying is a part of it is your
DNA we have to understand that there's a
part of it that is your DNA but and
you'll never be able to break free from
that or you just have to understand it
so that you know how to change no for
example you know if you know if you are
somebody that
um a personality
I can't change your personality to be
like XYZ
you know this whole concept about
modeling you know you got to model
somebody too much modeling leads to
imitation because you're not being you
right so speaking some people say well
Pat I don't see a lot of people speak
like you you speak differently I don't
know any other way to speak but I used
to try to speak like somebody else that
I was trying to model and I said no no
this is how I speak this is me this is
my method of delivering my message to
you makes sense great if it doesn't make
sense it doesn't make sense but the part
about the other side for me is I also
believe firmly that events conversations
certain individuals can completely say
something that can change your life
forever so what are some of the tools
that you use I know that you've talked
about Clarity is super important carrots
talk to us about those two things which
I think are both pretty powerful yeah
Tom I would say questions you know like
right now uh I I I'm more curious about
people that I can't even help myself I'm
asking you questions like hey you know
how come you don't have any kids we
don't have any kids why don't you have
any kids well because you know we
decided six years ago we're not gonna
have any kids but how did how did you
know that we got married 17 years ago
we've been together for 20 years and my
wife just so it was a decision and
emotional decision or a logical decision
I think it was a logical decision
because it was finally a way to get in
you know fulfillment what you and your
wife did is what very few people do and
the whole purpose of sitting down and
asking the questions what if I get asked
a question that I don't have the answer
to one of the scariest things about life
is a question
the the scary question can shake a soul
up
because no one's asked that question
from you so for me the transition for
somebody to want to change it and get
clarity is actually asking questions if
you don't ask the questions of what you
want to do next the world is going to
put you in the Box on what you have to
do next because they're determining who
you need to be and you are rising up to
their expectations because you're not
asking the questions yourself so Clarity
to me is stemmed from you being able to
sit down and ask those tough questions
that piss you off that irritate you that
make you emotional that you cry over
that you reflect that makes you want to
do research that makes you follow up
that makes you sit down and say I don't
really know I've never thought about
this before and that goes deeper and
deeper and deeper so Clarity is stamped
based on like the way you answer the
question to me Tom it was amazing so do
you have any kids no we made a decision
a long time ago we don't want to have
kids the way you said it was like very
nonchalant really it was so like let me
ask what we did then I said so tell me
how you processed it
it's very obvious that was a very
comfortable certain decision with a lot
of time put into it very few people do
that and then you've got Clarity and
Clarity gives confidence so somebody
looks at your eyes when you give the
answer there is no you know looking away
or uncomfortable or anything you're like
this is who we are this is the decision
we made but that Clarity came from all
the conversations you and your wife had
together I don't think enough people do
that together yeah no question one thing
in your book that you talked about that
I thought was really interesting was you
asked the question to your point about
questions when was the last time you
thought about your identity and you just
brought that up what's that process for
people how do you be like how what is
the identity which I think most people
give stats like what do you mean by that
and how can people begin to shape their
identity so Tom who were you in high
school
what was my identity yeah so if I was in
high school with you who were you you
were comedian thousand percent okay
comedian when did it change uh as soon
as I went to college I consciously
decided I wanted to become the artist
which was not necessarily the right
decision but that was yeah when I
changed and then what happened from
artist to Quest poverty
and so I so I start
um want to be the funny guy because I
need attention in high school by the end
of high school I'm very good at making
people laugh in a sort of living room
funny way I do countless hours of
practice of stand-up comedy and when I
go to college I'm like my only style of
humor is self-deprecating so I'm always
making fun of myself which actually
makes me think a little bit less of
myself so I very much had an inferiority
complex in high school I cheated my way
to being in the top 10 of my graduating
class I did terribly on my SATs and I
come into film school and I'm like this
is what I want to do with the rest of my
life like I actually want to be good at
this and that's one sort of realization
I'm grateful for was I realized at some
point you're in the big bad world and
you're either good or you're not and so
you better stop cheating really pay
attention and get good and so I thought
I need to take myself more seriously
stop making fun of myself so I didn't
tell anybody that I was you know a
comedic person or anything I didn't make
jokes nothing and so so I began to adopt
the identity of the artist I have some
artistic failures which creates this
identity crisis I'm very much in the
groups of poverty now because I've
graduated my parents aren't helping me
anymore I'm selling Insurance
door-to-door uh so what year is this
this is this would have been 99 wow so
20 years ago yeah so and and I'm just
like in this I'm sliding towards
depression I have no sense of how I can
make things come true this is all
pre-internet so like there's just
there's no hope for me like there's I
the idea to make a hundred thousand
dollar film which back then there was no
YouTube there was no video cameras you
could make movies on I mean it just
wasn't a thing so it was like 100 000
film might as well have been 100 million
dollar film so I'm stuck what am I gonna
do and that's when I meet these two
entrepreneurs who are like look you're
coming to the world with your handout
and if you want to control the art you
have to control the resources and so
that began a very long journey of
identity for me of figuring out who am I
how do I Define myself now and how is
that useful wow like understanding that
it is completely malleable I can decide
right now that I'm somebody else that my
identity is something new and something
different like I remember the day I told
people I was going to start lifting and
I just said right now today I'm lifting
and I told people I'm going to put on
muscle I'm going to look like Hugh
Jackman everybody's like yeah yeah right
and I just went beast mode and I just
started working out all the time and I
realized whoa like it's a demarcation
Line in the Sand yesterday at this time
I did not have the sense that I'm going
to become like Hugh Jackman that I am a
lifter I am somebody who sticks through
with what they say and now today I'm
just going to decide that is me and so I
began telling people it which gave all
this pressure that I had to live up to
it and I began to realize like whoa this
is a lever that you can pull and it
drives Behavior
[Music]